hey guys my name is just McDowell and it
is the fourth of July today which i
believe is some kind of important event
for some of you Americans if you do
happen to be celebrating today be sure
to have fun and be safe but for now
let's get into the top five day meetings
of the week starts up farm man I pick
the eSports controversy story for my
first one today so I'm just gonna wrap
this up as quick as I can and you can
check out Thursday's news episode for a
more specific rendition checks one
allowed to play hearthstone Inn finish
qualifiers for an upcoming international
eSports Federation tournament since the
qualifier was for a male-only tournament
anyway the organizers said we want to be
like a real sport so everyone can early
play with their own agenda and the
internet was like WTF may suddenly
change their mind now chicks can play
with the boys and play hearthstone as
well as coming they were in female
Tony's easy-peasy
then it was still a bit behind time
after that last lengthy story so let's
see what we can do about this next one
game stopper here to heal your sadness
caused by buying it connect you never
wanted with your xbox one and are
offering you 32 bucks for the camera or
what he does store credit so go do that
if you want to do that start on next up
the last service on ps4 is going to be
awesome that's according to the guys
making the last of us on ps4 Naughty Dog
dev Curt Morgan or tweeted that the game
in 60fps is a transformative experience
and that he couldn't go back we didn't
know for sure that the game was going to
be in 60 frames per second but we can
make a pretty good guess that it is now
The Last of Us remastered is coming to
ps4 on july 29th if you want to pick it
up sledgehammer have said that the new
call of duty game is going to have movie
grade realism in its visuals
specifically they've said you're gonna
be like oh man cool movie wait on a gosh
darn minute this is no movie this is a
game so please take a look at their
latest behind the scenes video and tell
me what you think about their attempts
to achieve photo realism they've been
using pretty intense mode capping and
carefully refining the character
animation so it should technically look
killer you know for all of the five
seconds you'll get to enjoy the shiny
detailed flex EXO suits before somebody
shoots you in the face
laughs up playstation boss Shuhei
Yoshida has that he doesn't get why some
gamers are only interested in big-budget
triple-a titles you see this whole font
of all knowledge games industry
international but he doesn't understand
gamers who only want to hear about
Triple A games he was worried that they
decided they just weren't interested or
worse hadn't even tried any he talked
about the time ps4 game resogun with a
free download for PS Plus subscribers
and how apparently not many people took
advantage of the deal nonetheless Sony
are pretty adamant about their love of
Indies and yoshida said that
understanding how they can push gamers
more toward excellent smaller sites
games is a key question for the company
be sure to let me know down in that
comment box at your triple-a aficionado
or an Indian thusi asst or both or
neither probably not neither anyway let
me know which and why as for what's on
site this week the gist covers some of
the very best III trailers you might
have missed Danny and Rob tell you
everything you need to know about soccer
or football and cam talks about how
drugs make you a better gamer maybe
check out the context for that one don't
do drugs anyway those are all the good
things I want to tell you about this
week have a wonderful fourth of July and
a great weekend and I will be back to
talk to you about more gamey things on
Monday